when you think of The Last of Us you
usually don't think of hidden secrets
and Easter eggs but the last of us is a
series that Revels in creating tiny aha
moments throughout its Journey if you
didn't get a chance to experience these
fun homages and legendary Tales here's
10 things you didn't know about The Last
of Us warning some of these can be
pretty spoiler heavy so proceed with
caution
[Music]
number 10 music to my ears in The Last
of Us Part 1 during the Bill's Town
chapter Ellie and Joel entered the
Marquee music store containing bands
that existed at the time of the outbreak
these can be found in the record store
in the enemy of my enemy segment of Left
Behind and the record store during the
downtown Seattle exploration section of
The Last of Us Part 2. these include the
blaggard boys full Funk and the
shambhalas although they may take a
namesake closer to the Backstreet Boys
the album art for the album into the
breach by the blaggard boys has a real
life counterpart in AC DC's 1981 album
For Those About to Rock We Salute You
the album unidentified objects by The
Band full Funk takes direct inspiration
from The 1975 album Mothership
Connection by the band Parliament and
the shambhalas are a naughty dog
Universe reference to the mystical City
that Nathan Drake discovers in Uncharted
2 but musically their album and evening
with the shambalas is more closely tied
to the 60s pop group The shangri-las and
it's important to note that Shangri-La
is another name used for the mythical
city of Shambhala I couldn't find the
names of the bands for these next
records but on the wall of the music
store you can find references to what's
going on by Marvin Gaye Blue by Joni
Mitchell and animals by Pink Floyd The
Last of Us Part 2 contains several real
life music inclusions when you track
down Nora in the hospital during Ellie's
section you can hear it was a good day
by Ice Cube playing at least sings A
melancholic version of Take On Me by Aha
tadina and two crooked still songs pop
up when you switch back to Ellie later
in the game Ain't No Grave plays while
Ellie is living in The Farmhouse with
Dina and JJ and little Sadie plays
during a flashback at the very end of
the game over a moment that Dina and
Ellie first kiss and some important
facts about the two songs themselves are
that although they're performed by
crooked still for the game Ain't No
Grave is actually a gospel song
originally written by Claude Ely it's
also famously covered by Johnny Cash and
little Sadie is a blue song and we don't
know the writer from 1922 but Bob Dylan
has a very famous cover in The Last of
Us Part 2 the song that Joel sings to
Ellie at the start of the game is a
Pearl Jam song called Future Days
according to gamespot's amazing editor
Jordan remade the Pearl Jam album with
this song on it released on October 13
2013. the outbreak day in The Last of Us
Universe was September 26th 2013. the
only version of that song existing
before release was a live performance in
July of that same year this means that
Joel was either at a Pearl Jam concert
in July of 2013 and remembered exactly
how the song went or found the
distribution plant for the CD because it
was never able to be fully released you
can also find the poster for the album
that the song is on called lightning
bolts in the music shop in downtown
Seattle where the band Pearl Jam is
originally from I like the idea of Joel
head banging at a Pearl Jam concert just
anything to give that man some happiness
number nine get your eyes checked kid a
small but poignant message is snuck into
the eye charts of the Firefly occupied
Hospital in The Last of Us Part One each
eye chart reads run you are nearly there
don't quit although fitting for the
horror stricken world of Last of Us I
would be terrified if I saw that at my
next eye exam
number eight well read both parts of The
Last of Us contain references to the
books that influence the series in The
Last of Us Part One Ellie carries a book
with her in the Lakeside Resort section
of the game the book is titled to get to
the other side written by Catherine
McCormick McCormick is a reference to
Cormac McCarthy the author of The
Pulitzer winning book the road the road
is the story of a father and son that
travel across a post-apocalyptic United
States two references to another book
round out the two major literary
influences Behind The Last of Us in The
Last of Us Part One a newspaper clipping
artifact that Joel and Ellie find in the
University section of the game lists the
journalist as Lev benioff this is a
reference to the 2008 book city of
Thieves written by David benioff
showrunner and writer of Game of Thrones
and features a protagonist named Lev the
connection to City of Thieves is
strengthened further during Abby's
portion of The Last of Us Part 2. during
Abby's section of Seattle day one she
wakes up after having fallen asleep
while reading city of Thieves and as
stated before Lev is the main character
of the novel novel which mirrors the
name of the young seraphite kid Lev who
becomes a major player in Abby's
character Arc
number 7 The Naughty Dog verse naughty
dog has placed references to its other
franchises inside The Last of Us games
here are a few standouts right after
meeting Henry and Sam you can find plush
toys based off of Nathan Drake Jack and
Daxter these are located in the child's
room in the serenity Apartments Jack and
Daxter up on the dresser and Nathan
Drake is on the bed similar to the plush
toys in the choo choo toy store a few
Uncharted and Jack and Daxter board
games are nestled into the far corner on
a shelf in Pittsburgh you can find a pub
named o'sullivans this is a referencing
Victor Sullivan of the Uncharted games
and B if you go inside it looks almost
identical to the pub at the beginning of
Uncharted 3 Drake's Deception right
outside O'Sullivan's as well as outside
the arcade and left behind sits Java
Jack a coffee cart referencing Jack from
Jack and Daxter in the Halloween store
and left behind Ellie finds both
Uncharted and Jack and Daxter themed
costumes the arcade in Left Behind is
called raja's arcade this is in
reference to Eddie and Rika Raja from
the Uncharted series games the Jack X
combat racing arcade game that is out of
order in raja's arcade is a reference to
the PS2 game of the same name in The
Last of Us Part 2 both Ellie and Eugene
have PS3s which also appear all over the
series in the mess hall Abby's friend
Jordan is playing the fire Canyon
section of Jack and Daxter the precursor
Legacy on Evita in the Westlake Bank in
downtown Seattle inside a security
deposit box is a ring with the
inscription sick parwas Magna this is
the seminal ring that belongs to Nathan
Drake in the Uncharted series
number six Don't Stop Me Now in The Last
of Us Part One On The Wall next to the
toy store there's a poster that says I
want to ride my bicycle with an image of
a top hat and a bike this is a reference
to the 1978 song Bicycle Race by Queen
number five not today capitalism in The
Last of Us Part One there are some
corporate mascots that represent much
Bleaker versions of their real-life
counterparts one very notable example is
the game of strife on the second floor
of the ranch house there is a board game
box labeled the game of strife this is a
much more somber version of the real
life board game the game of life
Number Four The Legend of ish throughout
the Last of Us Part One you can find a
selection of notes and artifacts hinting
at the lives of previous residents of
the areas you Traverse none leads you
down as intense a rabbit hole as the
resident of the sewers known as ish ish
did not start in the sewers in
Pittsburgh the first note you find from
him details that he was living on a
trawling boat and was away at Sea when
the outbreak occurred after running out
of supplies ish ran his motor ground
near the sewers and created a safe house
in them again running low in supplies he
scavenged the nearby suburbs where he
encountered Susan Kyle and their kids
ish offered them safety in the sewers
and they joined him to create a larger
Community branching off of his existing
Safe House the community thrived for a
while and grew to include Dany ish and
Danny served as the Protectors of The
Refuge salvaging weapons and armor off
of dead soldiers in the area during this
time we get the only depiction of ish as
drawn by one of the children in the camp
the piece would not last however the
door to the community was left open by
an unknown someone allowing a horde of
infected to clean out most of the camp
ish Susan and some of the children from
the community were able to escape into
the suburbs their whereabouts as of the
time of The Last of Us Part One are
unknown although this story is pieced
together through found artifacts and
notes the story of ish is not an
entirely original one ish is thought to
be a reference to isherwood ish Williams
the main character in the novel Earth
abides from 1949. in the novel Williams
creates a community of pandemic
survivors and is also a sailor with his
name being another reference to Ishmael
the main protagonist from Moby Dick
three movie Magic throughout the Last of
Us Parts one and two Visual and spoken
references to real life movies pop up
again and again in The Last of Us Part
One as Ellie and Joel explore the
serenity Apartments they can shiv open a
locked room that contains fictional
representations of real-life films these
include hair trigger referencing the
transporter the season of Vengeance
referencing the film The Last Samurai
and the lost kingdom which is in
reference to the Indiana Jones franchise
along with these posters the film dawn
of the wolf appears in many different
places throughout the Last of Us Part
One from its first appearance in Sarah's
bedroom to Billboards and movie posters
this fictional horror romance is a
direct reference to the Twilight series
in The Last of Us Part 2 in the Westlake
Bank Dina and Ellie discuss a movie with
Surfer bank robbers a reference to the
film Point Break starring the
illustrious Keanu Reeves in Abby's
section very early on Manny mentions
that he wants to watch a movie until he
passes out when Mel questions him about
which movie he's going to pick he States
he's going to watch a film where a girl
rides on a wolf due to his previous
admission of being an anime fan it's
highly probable that Manny is going to
watch one of my favorite movies of all
time Princess Mononoke
number 2 the 0451 code during Ellie's
first day in Seattle the gate code for
gate West 2 is 0451 this code pops up in
games such as System Shock System Shock
2 Bioshock Dishonored and thief the Dark
Project the code itself is an in
reference to the code used to get into
the offices of Looking Glass Studios
developers of system shocks 1 2 and
Thief it's important to know that
Naughty Dog are not the only Studio to
use this reference Looking Glass Studios
is so beloved by developers that this
code has appeared in at least 20 games
some that use the key code and some that
don't even have keypad technology in
them
number one The Last of Us Vice in the
same section that Ellie hunts down Nora
in the hospital on her day two in
Seattle the first combat encounter you
have upon entering the hospital is with
a young guard playing their Vita what
game are they so lost in Hotline Miami
another story of Revenge and Desperation
the hidden secrets in Easter eggs inside
The Last of Us series are as richly
cultivated and layered as the
performances and environments that
naughty dog has created I love that they
can make references to their own IPS as
well as other references in pop culture
while maintaining the tone and
atmosphere of The Last of Us we'll have
to see if the Last of Us Part One remake
hides any more treats for everything
else video games keep it here at
GameSpot